Joe Concha covers media for the hill and
he joins us right so Jeff you think that
the real problem with BuzzFeed is that
it has given rise to segments like this
where mean right wingers on Fox News
criticized NBC's it is that really the
core problem the story would you say
well Tucker let me address Chuck Todd
there because people don't realize this
but he's not only the moderator of Meet
the Press but he is also the political
director of NBC News so here's the thing
everybody all those anchors and pundits
you just show had ample warning that
there was a serious problem with this
story because on Friday morning before
all the impeachment if Cruz came out as
you mentioned you had Anthony Cormier
who was one of the authors in this piece
on CNN saying he hadn't seen the
evidence that was used as a foundation
for the story and then minutes later on
MSNBC Jason Leopold the other author on
here said he had seen the evidence that
is your red flag right there where Chuck
Todd as a political director then needs
to get the troops together and say guys
look our own news organization NBC News
could not verify this report
independently and therefore we should go
about this with extreme caution
instead you mentioned the number nearly
200 times on MSNBC alone the word in
Peecher impeachment was said 97 times
that falls at Chuck Todd's feet as a
political director when in the morning
meeting met it morning at a torah
meeting he should have made sure that
didn't happen and on CNN same thing they
couldn't verify the report independently
and it was said on there
82 times and now look where are we at
now
Jason Leopold the other reporter in the
story who said he saw the evidence is
like Edward Snowden you can't find him
he hasn't tweeted for three days hasn't
written any tweets anyway and he isn't
doing any interviews you see been so for
me it's always struck me as a real
reporter you know actually it to be
dontist about it but this Leopold kid
has like a long history of really
reckless behavior I mean he's the one
who publicly reported and turned out to
be false that Karl Rove had been
indicted I think he was fired for
plagiarism another time you guys a
political activist why would you ever
put someone like that on a story of this
magnitude precisely and it's it's
because with Leopold and so many in the
media the mistakes only seem to go one
way toward Republicans or conservatives
or Trump in this case I mean ask
yourself this question when was the last
time you saw a major media outlet make a
mistake or a major error in a story
about a Democratic lawmaker I I'm you
know racking my brain that's such a good
point think of never ago yeah yeah
watching for 30 years I've never seen
that happen ever not one time by the way
will you keep a list I mean I want to be
I want to be honest about it you know if
you see Nancy Pelosi unfairly impugned
by Chuck Todd will you let me know when
we'll do a segment on it just to correct
I'll be over I'll be all over by the way
Glenn Greenwald has a great piece today
in the intercept he lists ten major
stories that the media's gotten wrong on
Russia so this isn't a one-off like it's
being portrayed by some that are saying
oh there's just an excuse to attack the
media we've seen this over and olds up
and over again and as I mentioned going
in the same direction there's I don't
think is anyone braver than Glenn
Greenwald Joe thank you very much she's
great to see you thank you